Dr. Bradshaw had only been working at the
SCP Foundation for a few years, but in that
time, he had seen things that had changed
him irreparably.
Ancient texts about world-ending abominations,
machines that could spontaneously produce
any food or drink from nowhere, friendly slime
monsters with a penchant for tickling, invisible
kleptomaniac women and wannabe-heroic men
covered in spikes.
But one anomaly, in particular, stuck with
him, haunted his dreams, and dominated his
waking thoughts: SCP-049.
That mysterious masked doctor, with his deadly
touch and strange beaked visage, trying in
vain to cure something he would only refer
to as "The Pestilence" and "The Great Dying."
His "cure" was more like a curse, it seemed,
as his unusual treatments transformed his
patients into the mindless living dead, shuffling
around as malformed shells of their former
selves.
If this was the cure, Dr. Bradshaw found himself
often wondering, what was the disease?
Many researchers had attempted to get to the
bottom of this question over the years, interviewing
SCP-049 and nurturing their own pet theories
in their free time, but none had ever received
a satisfactory answer, ever reached a real
conclusion.
It was this legacy of fruitless hypothesizing
and questioning that led Dr. Bradshaw to pitch
his own plan for unmasking the Pestilence
once and for all.
He would gather every prominent theory his
colleagues could come up with, including several
of his own.
Then, he would simply engage the Plague Doctor
in polite discourse, walking him through each
theory one by one and waiting to see if any
of them stuck.
It took Dr. Bradshaw weeks to collect and
distill the theories down into a workable
list of questions, consolidating those that
overlapped and eliminating those that were
simply ridiculous (such as Dr. Bright's potentially
facetious insistence that the Pestilence was
lactose intolerance), but when the day came,
he felt ready to take on the task.
When the interview was through, perhaps he
would have managed to do what none before
him at the Foundation had.
Perhaps he would understand what the Plague
Doctor was fighting with his unorthodox methods,
and by extension, how they could pacify him
non-lethally, once and for all.
Dr. Bradshaw held his notebook tight as he
made the long walk down the hall from his
office to SCP-049's containment room.
This was it, the moment of truth...he hoped.
He had asked his colleagues to pump the scent
of lavender into 049's room to put him at
ease, as well as give him his dinner just
in time for the meeting.
He hoped that the meal, a little glass of
wine, and the peaceful atmosphere would make
the Plague Doctor more amenable to his line
of questioning.
SCP-049 was sitting in front of the wide glass
window, fork and knife in hand, when Dr. Bradshaw
arrived.
"Hello, Doctor."
Bradshaw gave 049 a wave.
"Ah, good evening!
They told me I would be having company for
dinner.
But where is your food, sir?"
"Oh, I'm not hungry..."
Dr. Bradshaw brushed him off politely.
"Nonsense!
It would be horribly rude for me to eat while
you have nothing.
Excuse me!"
He called to a guard nearby.
"Please bring this man a helping of what you've
served me so we may dine together!"
With a sigh, Dr. Bradshaw nodded at the guard,
giving him permission to do what the Plague
Doctor asked.
A few moments later, he too had a tray with
a plate of fish and roasted vegetables, and
a small cup of wine on the side.
"Now, may I ask you some questions?"
The Plague Doctor nodded.
"Indeed.
What is it that I can do for you?"
"I was hoping you could teach me more about
The Pestilence..."
Dr. Bradshaw began delicately.
The Plague Doctor perked up.
"Have you come to assist me with my work?
My dear fellow, why did you not say so from
the start?
It would be my honor to provide you with all
the knowledge I possess on the subject, if
you intend to lend a hand."
"I just want to understand more about it first,"
Dr. Bradshaw said.
It wasn't quite a lie, not really.
He did want to understand.
He flipped open his notebook, scanning the
page for the first of the posited theories
he had gathered.
"Is it possible that when you refer to the
Pestilence, you're talking about pain as a
whole?"
The Plague Doctor cocked his head to the side.
"What do you mean?"
"Well.
You once described SCP-096 as being afflicted
with an extreme case of The Pestilence, I
believe.
And when you...cure someone, they're no longer
able to feel any pain, physical or emotional.
I know that you mean well, but is it possible
that's what you're trying to treat?
The pain that naturally afflicts all human
life, most living things?"
The Plague Doctor scoffed.
"You think that I, a physician, am so ignorant
of pain?
That I would misdiagnose agonies as something
so devastating as The Great Dying?
If you are here to insult me, sir, I will
simply ask that you leave."
"I'm sorry, that wasn't my intention.
Please, let me stay.
I promise I am only here to try and understand.
Will you withhold judgment until I'm finished?
One man of science to another?"
The Plague Doctor paused, mulling this over.
He nodded.
"I will hear your questions and do my best
to answer them."
"Thank you."
Dr. Bradshaw smiled, and returned to his notes.
"So, you have been in the field of medicine
for quite some time, and I imagine you've
studied a variety of sciences.
You work with a lot of liquids and substances
none of us have encountered before, were they
the result of alchemy?
Used to balance the humors of your patients?
I was curious if your treatments, and if the
Pestilence itself, is thaumaturgical in nature.
That is to say, well...magical."
The Plague Doctor let out a sharp laugh at
this.
"Magic?
Sir, I am no magician.
Nor am I an alchemist, as I have never formally
studied alchemy in any form.
The humors, of course, must be balanced for
proper health, but that has nothing to do
with alchemy, in my opinion.
How is your black bile?
You appear to have an excess of it.
Do you find you experience a great deal of
stomach pain?"
Dr. Bradshaw rushed to steer the topic away
from him and his health, lest the Plague Doctor
offer to treat him.
"Not particularly.
Next question..."
His eyes returned to his notes.
"Let's see...We've noticed that you seem to
cure those who are most afraid of death and
dying.
And when you first arrived at our facility,
you stated that there was less Pestilence
here than other places you had been.
Most of our staff have seen enough death and
misfortune that it no longer frightens us,
we're inoculated against it, essentially.
One Researcher working with you was afraid
of death at first, but as he came to accept
it as an inevitability, you said that he was
no longer infected.
Is the Pestilence fear itself, or more specifically,
the fear of death?"
The Plague Doctor mulled this over.
"One's outlook, one's attitude, can impact
their health.
It is easier to fight a disease when one does
not let fear take over.
But other than that, I am afraid I do not
understand your question.
The Pestilence is simply what it is.
Why are you more preoccupied with categorizing
it than curing it?"
"I believe that to understand something is
to know how to fight it," Dr. Bradshaw answered
simply.
"We may differ there.
But you may continue.
I am grateful for the company.
And for your desire to understand, misguided
though it may be."
"Thank you, Doctor.
I wanted to ask you, are you familiar with
the Scarlet King?"
The Plague Doctor's expression did not change.
"I have seen the rise and fall of many monarchs
in my time Why would you ask me about the
Scarlet King?"
That wasn't a "no."
"Well," Dr. Bradshaw began, "According to
legend, one of his many daughters was Pestilence,
a bringer of disease and destruction.
Is she the one you intend to fight?"
"I know not every single form the Pestilence
takes, only the grip it has on this world,"
SCP-049 answered.
"For your sake, I would advise you to avoid
speaking of such matters.
That King...he is not a thing you wish to
face."
Dr. Bradshaw jotted down a quick note in the
margin of the page: "Scarlet King Connection
possible."
Then, he returned to his line of questioning.
"Have you spoken with SCP-343?"
"I have."
The Plague Doctor nodded.
"And what did he tell you?"
"It is not worth going into here..."
"According to him, the Pestilence that you
refer to is humanity's free will.
You were changed by something a long time
ago, a tragedy, that turned you toward your
work.
You came from a dark place, one of the places
even 343 can't see.
Is that true?"
"I will not answer that question.
It is an insult," SCP-049 said.
Again, not a "no," exactly.
But still, Dr. Bradshaw did not want to push
too hard too soon and risk the Doctor terminating
their conversation.
"My apologies.
I'll shift to something different.
You once treated the bubonic plague, correct?"
SCP-049 shook his head.
"I am not familiar with that particular condition,
no."
Dr. Bradshaw had prepared for this.
He pulled a medical ilustration from his notebook,
depicting a victim of The Black Plague.
"What about something like this?"
SCP-049 sighed.
"Ah, now this ailment I have encountered before.
I did my best to treat it, but...it was stubborn."
"Is it related to The Pestilence?"
Dr. Bradshaw asked.
"Not necessarily."
049 said nothing more than that.
He took a sip of wine, ate a bite of potato.
He wasn't going to offer any more insight
into that particular theory, it seemed.
"I mean no offense with this next question,
but Doctor...have you always lived here?
On this planet?
Or did you make your way here from another
world of some kind?
Perhaps the Pestilence came from wherever
you did."
"The world has changed around me a great deal
in my life," SCP-049 said.
"But I have always been here.
At least, as best as I can recall."
He seemed to be telling the truth, but with
that unmoving, inscrutable expression, it
was difficult to be sure.
This next theory would be extremely difficult
to float without offending SCP-049, but Dr.
Bradshaw had to try.
He needed to do his due diligence.
"Are you familiar with the story of Typhoid
Mary?"
He would ease into the idea, that would be
best.
"I am not."
SCP-049 sounded puzzled.
"She was an asymptomatic carrier of Typhoid,"
Dr. Bradshaw explained.
"As others grew sick around her, she remained
healthy and well.
She had no idea that, as she worked as a cook
in the houses of wealthy families, she was
infecting them all with a deadly disease.
It was not any moral failing of her own, she
didn't understand what she was doing, but
she still spread the virus throughout her
community-"
"Stop right there."
The Plague Doctor's tone was stern, tense.
"I know what you are suggesting, and it offends
me to my core.
If you do not cease these vile implications
I will be forced to end our talk here and
now.
I am a physician, sir, I do not endanger my
patients so recklessly."
"I understand."
Better to leave that theory alone for now.
"You said that you have always been here,
but I do have to ask...have you ever heard
of a place called Alagadda?
There are those that claim you once lived
there, that you came from that kingdom."
"I have never heard that name, that I can
recall.
But I have lived a long life, perhaps I have
forgotten.
What nation does it belong to?"
Dr. Bradshaw paused.
It was his turn to be stumped.
"I'm not sure.
Do you know who The Black Lord is?"
He couldn't be certain, but he thought he
saw SCP-049 frown.
"Villain!
A villain," he grumbled under his breath.
"I banish him from my thoughts, that he may
never again enter my sight."
His gloved hands clenched into fists, and
Dr. Bradshow jotted down another note in the
margins.
The Black Lord.
He had devoted plenty of time to everyone
else's theories, it was time for one that
he had been earnestly considering.
"Doctor, it is my opinion that the Pestilence
may be connected to emotional state or heart
rate, perhaps both.
When you treat your patients, do you remove
the heart or the amygdala to address those
issues?
I have noticed heart removal during a handful
of your procedures."
"You have a keen eye!"
SCP-049 enthused.
"However, I do not always remove the heart.
It varies greatly from patient to patient,
you see.
For some, the heart is a crucial part of the
infection.
For others, it impacts the brain.
Others still, the liver or the larger nervous
system.
That is why it is so difficult to treat, you
see.
It can manifest in seemingly infinite ways."
"But what about emotions?
Negative impulses?
Cruelty, selfishness, hatred.
Is that a component?
I was reviewing your file, and you mentioned
an excess of the Pestilence in the home of
a wealthy man known for exploiting his workers
and mistreating his famiy.
When you were cross-tested with SCP-682 you
remarked that the Pestilence did not only
impact humans, suggesting the anomaly was
also infected.
And your cured patients, well, they don't
seem to have a hateful impulse in their bodies."
"Hate...can be a disease."
The Plague Doctor took another bite of food,
chewing slowly.
When he swallowed, Dr. Bradsaw expected him
to elaborate on this thought.
But he didn't.
"So..."
Dr. Bradshaw broke the silence.
"The four horsemen of the apocalypse, the
ones that bring about the end of the world.
War, famine, death, and...pestilence.
There have been stories about them for thousands
of years.
Do you know Pestilence personally?
Are you protecting us from him, from the end
of days?"
SCP-049 scoffed.
"I work in science, not in stories.
I intend no disrespect to your beliefs, but
surely you hear how absurd that sounds.
Pestilence does not ride in on a horse.
It resides in the body."
"You've lost patients before, haven't you?"
"Every physician has, if what they are treating
is severe.
It never gets any easier to do so."
"I'm sure.
Have you ever lost someone special to you,
though?
Done something you truly regret?"
Perhaps the Pestilence was a manifestation
of some guilt or trauma, some shame he could
never truly let go.
"Every man has regrets.
Do you not have those secret shames, Doctor?"
Dr. Bradshaw changed the subject.
"I have always wondered this.
Can you see the misdeeds that someone has
done?
Can you somehow sense the sins of their past,
all the harm they have caused?"
"Why do you ask?"
SCP-049 cocked his head again.
"Are you afraid I can see something within
you?"
He couldn't explain why, but the question
made his stomach turn.
"No."
He answered.
It was a lie.
"Will everyone catch the Pestilence eventually?"
"As time goes on, the odds do become greater,
yes.
But not everyone is doomed."
"Is that it?
Is it time?
The passage of time, aging, decay.
The Great Dying, you called it.
So...is it dying, itself?
Your cured patients, they don't age.
They'll never decay any more than they already
have."
"Death is not natural," SCP-049 simply said.
"All things die eventually."
Dr. Bradshaw argued.
"I have not died yet."
SCP-049 took a drink of wine.
Well, there was no arguing with that.
"Something else I've been thinking about,
is the possibility that the Pestilence is
greater than just one thing."
Dr. Bradshaw began his next theory.
"Doctors believed at one time that the Plague
was caused by an imbalance of the humors in
the body.
They could recognize the presence of disease,
but couldn't routinely tell them all apart.
Several different illnesses were referred
to as Consumption, and Leprosy was used as
a catch-all for multiple illnesses as well.
Clearly, you have a knack for knowing when
someone is ill, but what if it's something
else?
Something equally bad, but different from
what you think?
It's cancer, or a stroke, or a heart condition.
There is no one cure, except for the massive
transformational work you're already doing."
"Possibly," SCP-049 mused.
"I will need to consider that point carefully.
Perhaps you have unlocked a secret to the
Pestilence I missed.
Then again, perhaps not."
"If the Pestilence is not death...then I do
have to wonder.
Is it the opposite?
Life is a temporary state for so many of us
less lucky than you, and it seems like you
cure your patients of natural life when you
treat them.
They become something not quite dead but not
quite living, at least not as they were.
And illness, ailments, hurt, all comes as
a natural side effect of being alive.
So is the Great Dying...life itself?"
"I do not understand the question, and thus,
I will not respond to it," SCP-049 stated.
Dr. Bradshaw could sense that The Plague Doctor
was growing frustrated, getting tired of so
many questions that poked at his beliefs,
his research, his process.
"Is the Pestilence natural, or something manmade?
Humans have created diseases before, caused
them to mutate, or worsened them with chemicals
we invent.
Have you heard of Agent Orange?
I don't mean to digress, but my point is,
it's not unheard of for people to be responsible
for a disease.
I wonder...is the Pestilence something that
developed on its own?
Or is it our doing?
A biological weapon, a synthesized virus or
artificial mutation created by other scientists?
Or maybe..."
Dr. Bradshaw paused here, referring once more
to his notes.
"Is it sin?
Greed, lust, wrath, pride, envy, gluttony,
sloth...maybe not that biblical, that exact,
but is it evil?
The sort of thing that rots away at the human
soul?
Not a plague of the body, but of the very
essence, and the only way to cure it is to
rip the whole thing out and start over?"
"You seem to have the answers in mind before
you ask me these questions, Doctor.
I will allow you one more before I take my
leave, I have found this whole ordeal quite
exhausting."
Dr. Bradshaw nodded.
"Okay, just one more.
Is it something unnatural, not manmade, not
of nature, viruses or bacteria, but something
else altogether?
Something from another dimension, another
world, or the spaces in between.
You have been cagey about the nature of the
Pestilence for as long as you have been here,
and I understand if you are just being cautious,
but...I can't help but wonder if there is
something else to the reason you keep so much
to yourself.
You promised to tell me about the Pestilence,
but you've barely responded to most of my
questions except to dismiss my ideas.
Is the Pestilence something that spreads by
thought?
That lives in the consciousness, or the subconscious,
of us all?
Waiting, dormant, for something to activate
it and set the sickness free?"
The Plague Doctor set down his fork with a
clatter.
"I respect your scientific curiosity, but
there are things I cannot share with you.
For my safety, for yours, for everyone's.
Do take care, Doctor."
"You too."
Dr. Bradshaw stood from his chair, collecting
his notes and preparing to leave.
"One final thing..."
Dr. Bradshaw turned back to face the Plague
Doctor.
"Yes?"
Those dark eyes watched him from inside the
mask.
"Do you see any of the Pestilence in me?"
The silence that passed between them felt
like an eternity.
Then…
SCP-049 spoke.
"No, sir.
I do not.
But one day, that could change."
As Dr. Bradshaw made his way back to his office,
the words echoed in his mind, and he couldn't
make up his mind whether they were comforting,
or troubling.
He had gone in to the meeting with questions,
but now, he had even more than he started
with.
We'd like to thank all of your for your responses,
and a special thanks to Knitt_Whitt, SilentZieth,
Conniepoo, Aidan Carrillo, Rick Astley's Clone,
Billysayboo, zeldacraft_64, Pyronaught682,
Pyriel, Amy Child, Mistrz bober, Huji Juni,
ChickenGirl, Samuel Saunders, stomyn, nicktwolf
discusses, ZetaTheMeta, DrAGoni_Penguin, L.P,
Makishi Mirian and Aidan Eaglesfield for your
contributions to this video!
Check out our community tab for your ideas
or theories to become part of another video
like this!
Now go check out “A Day in the Life of SCP-049”
and “Can SCP-049 Cure the Pestilence in
SCP-3008 Infinite Ikea?”
for more of everyone’s favorite anomalous
scientist!